hey folks if you'd like to support me or
this channel move university in creating
more video tutorials then please
consider making a financial contribution
at my website move university I found
thanks and enjoy the video
I'd like to wrap up the discussion of
lipids by talking about steroids and
steroids so their basic structure is
based on this idea of a steroid nucleus
steroid nucleus which I've drawn here
it's these this four ring system three
of them are six membered rings in this
last one is a five membered ring and
this whole situation is nearly planar
the Rings are referred to as the a ring
B ring C ring and D ring now so all
steroids have this basic structure basis
basic four ring system they vary
slightly from one to the other
but they have that same same sort of
situation going on their functions they
function as membrane components and they
can also function as signaling molecules
namely hormones the major sterile in
animals is cholesterol and its structure
is like this
it looks like that it is a a it is an
amphipathic molecule which means it has
polar and nonpolar portions it's polar
portions actually pretty small it's just
this o age group here all right it's
going to pull ROH the rest of the
molecule that was just hydrocarbons
right carbons and hydrogen's so the rest
of it is nonpolar which is why it can
actually be a membrane component it
specifically in membranes it plays a
role in maintaining membrane fluidity so
if it gets too cold and a membrane sort
of begins to become more rigid
cholesterol play a role in helping it
become more fluid and if it becomes a
little bit too fluid and might break
apart
it becomes allows it to become a little
bit more rigid to maintain optimal
fluidity levels so cholesterol plays an
important role there it's also important
as a precursor to other steroid
molecules in fact something that's
actually pretty important to that is the
numbering system of cholesterol 27
carbons long and it's numbered like this
starting from carbon number one right
there and we go around 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 then we jump up here at 11 12 13 14
15 17 then these two methyl groups 18 19
and then 20 through 27 are on this this
end over here is the numbering system
might not seem really important right
now but there are certain enzymes
involved in them in sort of converting
one I mean or what not you may not want
amino acid one steroid molecule to
another and the the names of the enzymes
sometimes refer to where they're
actually doing whatever it is they're
doing for as an example there's an
enzyme called there's an enzyme called
5-alpha reductase and what that does
that molecule is actually what takes
testosterone
testosterone and turns it into a dye
dihydrotestosterone which or DHT
and the enzyme name 5 alpha reductase
it's action it's it's reducing the 5
carbon of testosterone to to become
dihydrotestosterone or DHT so that's
just one example there are other
examples but the point is that being
familiar with the numbering system of
the steroids is helpful understanding
the names of the enzymes in case you're
studying those pathways ok next up here
bile acids so there are bile acids that
are that are steroids and there their
function really is to emulsify fats from
our diet and what that means is
basically it takes these these gigantic
fats that we're consuming and breaks
them up into a little smaller sort of
molecules that that lipases can act on
and lipases will go through and and
break down the fats further from there
so I've just drawn here an example of a
specific bile acid called Toro Kolak
acid and the reason the Toro portion of
that name comes from this portion up
here called taurine and that taurine
portion actually carries the acidic this
is a group that is carrying the negative
charge after it has been deprotonated
now steroid hormones steroid hormones so
these are the ones that I think a lot of
people study these first two up here are
the sex steroids and they are made in
the reproductive organs so over here
I've drawn the male sex steroid and over
here I've drawn the female sex steroid
the male sex steroid is made in the male
reproductive organ which is the testes
and the female sex steroid is made in
the ovaries
female reproductive organ so which two
steroids are these you may already have
guessed it
this one is testosterone and this one is
estradiol the names can make a little
bit of sense this this test refers to
the fact that these things are made in
the testes steyr comes from the SD er
steroid and then ome refers to ketone so
we got a ketone right there so it's
basically saying male sex steroid and it
has a key to estradiol estro refers to
estrus and the the dial refers to two
alcohols there's an alcohol there all
there so these names can make a little
bit of sense they're not always surefire
but they can they can sometimes make a
little bit sense okay next up 3 & 4 3 &
4 are the corticosteroids because they
are made in the adrenal cortex so cortex
cortical corticosteroids they're also
called corticoids for short the first
one over here to the left is a
glucocorticoid and this one over here to
the right is a mineralocorticoid
mineralocorticoid and you may have
guessed the names of these this one is
cortisol and this one is aldosterone
cortisol is a stress hormone and the
reason it's called a glucocorticoid is
because of its effects on blood glucose
levels aldosterone is a
mineralocorticoid because of its effects
on the minerals in our body specifically
sodium right sodium is a mineral and so
aldosterone plays a role in sodium
levels so so it's a mineralocorticoid
and the own against again here the own
refers to ketone cortisol also has a
ketone but it doesn't have it
doesn't end and own but up here it does
have some alcohol so that Oh L might
refer to these alcohol is up here
cortisol's name doesn't really lend too
much to its structure but cortisol and
aldosterone are both corticoids because
they were made and released from the
adrenal cortex this last one here number
five is a synthetic cortisone Oh
synthetic corticosteroid synthetic
Kotick Oh steroid and it's actually
called a prednisone
okay so prednisone is used to treat anti
inflammatory diseases anti inflammatory
diseases and it is an immunosuppressant
drug so although it can treat anti
inflammatory diseases because of its
immunosuppressive effects it can leave
pastéis patients susceptible to
infections so I don't know I'm just as
soon as I heard that I thought okay so
if someone is taking prednisone for some
sort of disease we might want to make
sure that you know we make sure that
everything that we give them is pretty
clean and free from infections because
they're especially susceptible to
infections
now all these steroid hormones can
basically are important in signaling so
because they are steroid hormones they
can they will somehow make their way to
the nucleus of of a cell and alter gene
transcription these guys alter they
exert their effects by altering
transcription of of genes okay well I
hope that video was helpful in kind of
introducing steroids and wrapping up
lipids thanks for watching yo if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
Like comment subscribe for more content
and if you know anybody who might find
the videos helpful then please share it
with them Thanks happy studying